i think as many men as possible should
join women's sports you are missing out
why wouldn't you go and win some medals
for yourself in this rigged system it
makes no sense you don't even have to do
anything you don't have to cut anything
off you just identify it doesn't matter
and also what that's going to do is i
actually think that could help a lot of
people because if you had a mass wave of
people join women's sports tomorrow then
that would force the hand of a lot of
lawmakers and politicians to say
ah this really isn't making sense we're
going to have to do something about this
um it would rip the band-aid off i think
it would red pill tons of parents and
people partaking in these sports i think
anyone watching this if you are a man
that you know has the ability to go have
some fun and join some women's leagues
go do it absolutely win all those medals
while you can in this brief period of
history and save our nation in the
process of doing that you know yeah you
know a few women might lose scholarships
but that's better than
uh our whole nation being in delusion
for the rest of eternity
[Music]
welcome to episode 151 of my podcast i'm
michaela peterson today's guest is
lauren southern i haven't spoken to her
very much since i first started
podcasting but i had her back on to
discuss her recent documentary american
mirage about the american immigration
crisis you can actually watch the entire
thing on youtube i've linked it in the
show notes we also spoke about politics
hyper individualization trans athletes
rumors online the san bernardo massacres
and more i hope you enjoy this
conversation please consider subscribing
if you do
before we get started this episode was
sponsored by bio optimizers if you
experience anxiety depression stress or
have trouble sleeping i always recommend
going low carb it's changed my life but
there's a super easy to implement thing
most of us forget about or don't know
about magnesium
fifty percent of americans are magnesium
deficient
isn't that crazy
50
magnesium helps with depression anxiety
diabetes blood pressure and even fat
metabolism and digestion as magnesium is
the body's master mineral and powers
over 300 critical reactions and again 50
percent of americans are deficient
magnesium breakthrough by bio optimizers
is a supplement with all seven organic
forms of magnesium and cofactors like
manganese and vitamin b6 for enhanced
stress relief and performance
many users report immediately noticing
the effects most magnesium supplements
are synthetic or only have a couple of
types of magnesium in them magnesium
breakthrough is the only supplement like
this on the market
make it a habit be in charge of your
well-being just take one before bed
every night and see how you feel the
next day here's an exclusive offer to
get you started visit
magbreakthrough.com peterson or use code
peterson at checkout for 10 off
magbreakthrough.com peterson i hope you
enjoy this episode
[Music]
lauren southern welcome to my
podcast thanks for having me before we
uh i mean actually hit the record button
we were just talking about how much [ __ ]
you get on the internet
yes both of us
yeah you as well
you guys
rough it can be rough
yeah it's always good to have a mix of
both like accusations of being a
far-right terrorist and then also people
going after your family you know you got
to get that good balance between the two
but what i was saying that your producer
was like oh say that again lauren was i
i was on like a podcast a few weeks ago
and people were bringing up in the
comments and whatnot they're like oh
michaela peterson is a fraud she's she
just made up this lion diet she's
scamming people and every time i see
that it triggers me so much because i
remember hanging out with you what year
would this have been that you came to my
little i think it was 20 square foot
apartment i think it was 2016.
yeah this is like 2016. yeah before you
had social media presents you did you
have brown hair then am i crazy yeah
yeah yeah you did so it was yeah it was
before blonde hair was a while ago a
while ago and
we had a glass of wine and you just kept
going off about oh lord i've had all
these autoimmune issues i'm obsessed
with like this new diet thing i'm
creating i'm eliminating all of these
different foods i remember going for
dinner with your family
and you got you only putting meat on the
table and i had no context
what's wrong with these people why are
they only serving like meat for every
dish so this is like for anyone who
thinks this is like some crazy fraud
that you and your dad are trying to scam
people over no they've always been this
weird guys this is like you're getting
full unfiltered real weirdness that
works for them and a lot of people i
appreciate that i appreciate that i
think you actually came did you come
over for dinner in 2016 and then i we
hung out at your place a couple of weeks
later
yeah that was weird yeah
you didn't tell me at all about your
like only meat diet so it's just sitting
there
i'm like where's the salad guys anything
yeah no we were it was a bit yeah it's
awkward at the beginning
whatever it is what it is i love weird
people i love weird people that was a
lot of fun it was good um chatting with
you but yeah it was like right before
that powder cake just blew up and then
your dad was an international celebrity
man that must have done a lot to your
psyche like how did that affect you
michaela on the on the lauren southern
podcast um
how did that how did that affect me
honestly like
i was kind of i was so wrapped up in
health things at the time i mean you
hung out with me it was like hung out
and i just talked about like whoa this
is crazy i'm eliminating things and i'm
getting better isn't that crazy like the
first time we hung out so i think i was
so wrapped up in like my autoimmunity
disappearing with dietary changes that i
was like that's serious that's like
incurable disorders
going into remission and then dad
blowing up online i was like it was hard
to
understand how much of that was like
just the online world because i was kind
of
not attached to it so it only started
impacting me i think if really
dad went on tour so then i didn't see
him as much and then a few years later
when they started getting it started
getting really personal for like online
articles attacking
like health really
and my family like that started to
impact me but
at the time
i think it was too new
plus it was like what does that even
mean and how long is this going to last
and we didn't know what was going on so
i think i was too wrapped up in health
stuff at the time yeah well that's
that's a nice little trade-off you
finally get rid of like your physical
health issues and then you get
them for a bunch of mental health issues
caused by internet fame so that's really
cool
yeah super fun
super fun okay okay lauren you were on
my podcast when i first launched the
podcast
like right right at the beginning when
oh my gosh life was so bad
i was in serbia with dad that's where i
filmed with you and he was so sick and
life was so bad
but you came on my podcast that was a
long time ago and now you're back so for
anyone who doesn't know
you somehow can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do
yeah i was a big far-right internet
villain for many years um started in
politics when i was like 18 19
kind of at the crux of the trump
movement 2016 gamergate all that stuff
and then i disappeared
for a year in 2018 2019 2019
um
focus on family all of that and now i'm
back
and more irrelevant than ever zealous
internet celebrity over here
no but uh no it's good i'm just making
videos here and there on my political
interests just coming out with a new
documentary called american mirage in
fact it is out tomorrow super exciting
on the immigration crisis to the us
um yeah so just focusing on on these uh
more specific projects rather than kind
of i did i did the whole
viral streeter like hot content for a
long time but uh i'm kind of enjoying
this more chill arc
yeah that's fair that's fair okay an
immigration documentary so like to keep
out it's so funny it's so funny my uh
fiance is kind of like he's like all
american
i wouldn't say he's anti-immigrant but
like he makes immigrant jokes
occasionally and i'm like you you know
you're marrying one how does it feel how
does it feel coming in here stealing
your jobs as an immigrant that's what
i'm doing
jordan so true well this this
documentary is actually entirely from
the perspective of the migrants
themselves um the reason that i do that
in a lot of cases is because people
perceive my work as anti-immigrant all
the time
um and also because americans tend to
not
look at the border situation or
understand the border situation until it
actually enters america i think looking
at it from the immigrants perspective
gives you a new a new view on what's
going on um
at the at the mexican border and then it
also makes it
far more difficult to criticize because
i can see people criticizing and saying
you're only looking from the american
perspective lauren you're only looking
at these people as you know not human
beings they're just like a horde of
invaders or whatever well no even when
you look at these situations from the
migrants perspective this is a messy and
broken situation we're dealing with the
american migration process or lack
thereof right
it doesn't matter whose perspective you
look at it from it it's it's messy and
something needs to change
okay can you um can you give me a
background about exactly what's going on
that's an interesting perspective i
think valuable so what what is what's
the problem and as a canadian i'm like
eh it's america's problem um
but now i'm in america so what exactly
is the problem with immigration between
i guess on the lower border
well i i'd say certainly from the
migrants perspective there is no real
immigration system they hear every day
of friends or family that will apply to
legally go to america and they never get
a call back they never get maybe 15
years waiting in the system or never
anything because they don't have the
financial support they don't have the
job background they don't have someone
they're tied to in the u.s that can
bring them over so the idea of legally
immigrating is
impossible for some of these people and
then they hear time and time again a
friend who's now living in california
new york wherever that
did a month-long trek over the border
and they're living it up and they start
to assume that well that's just the
process you have to go through
especially coming from broken countries
where you know they've got a corrupt
government and if you want to get
anything done you have to pay off a few
cops you have to pay off a few
government officials they look at
america and they're like it's the same
if i want to immigrate there i just have
to go there illegally i have to get a
coyote this is the process to becoming
an american is paying interest is going
over elite illegally and that's very
similar to our own governments and you
know what they're not wrong to think it
because america have been letting it
happen for years and years and years and
they're legalizing these people they're
allowing them to live in america after
they immigrate illegally so why are
immigrants supposed to think any
different
that's interesting so it actually is the
process basically yeah basically now it
is you're i you are a thousand
especially if you're one of these people
coming from south america you don't have
a passport anymore you're someone that's
poor living in mexico why
you're not gonna get through legally and
everyone you know that does get over is
typically getting through illegally
why would you do anything else and you
know they even think of it you have to
pay like three thousand five thousand
bucks to some of these coyotes to go
over the border and funny enough a lot
of people could just walk over
themselves but in certain regions
the coyotes or
the cartel will actually shoot you at
night if you try to walk over yourself
because they want to make sure that it's
known you have to go through us you
can't just you know make your own way
um so they're like okay yeah when i get
to the border i pay the cartel that's
part of the process and then i get to
become an american
so they actually
they just view that as yeah the system
so did you go down there and do
interviews yeah so i went all the way
down to guatemala
and we
i actually illegally crossed into
guatemala but what i've seen oh my gosh
can you say that
okay to say it it costs 20 pesos
i think that's like 99 cents not even so
it costs 20 pesos there and back to go
illegally into guatemala and i'm not
kidding the uh boats that they have that
you take over with these human
traffickers sometimes they are
literally underneath official
immigration checkpoints it's like taking
the piss
you've got the official checkpoint you
can go and do the whole stupid passport
process or you just go under the bridge
and pay 20 pesos and
go to guatemala yeah so we went there we
had a few beers we uh spoke to the
locals that were living across the
sushiate river and then um yeah we
hopped on the boat went back to mexico
and took the whole trek we followed we
followed the track that they would take
straight from
the waterfront all the way to the u.s
border order reynosa
you're insane this is why people attack
you online like who does that
were you stressed out about that at all
um i had armed security do you
experience stress lauren
i think i thrive in chaos michaela okay
it's not good it's not healthy but i do
i try to make it organized chaos enough
that i won't die and what i've learned
after all these trips is um
as long as you have a local that's
pretty savvy and knows the area and has
connections you'll be pretty okay so i
had i had a really great security team
my one local guy who who was armed you
know always had the glock in the back of
his pants and then
he'd been in shootouts with sicarios and
everything before as well great guy
um and then we had
like a crew that were back at their
kind of intel office that would call the
local police and cities that we were
going to and they had great intel like
we were in a city called tierra blanca
and we had three police officers come up
to us and our
um you know intel guys let us know hey
sicarios know you're here they're
watching you so you should get out of
the town before nightfall because
obviously they want to kidnap foreign
crews especially camera crews that they
can get money off of and whatnot so we
got out of that city before nightfall
got to a safe uh different place
veracruz
and as long as you kind of had that
connection or conversation and made sure
you were allowed to do things when i was
in tamalepas we spoke to the cartel and
they let us know areas that we were
allowed to film otherwise they'd shoot
us so we didn't go and film there right
that's fair i mean as long as they're
kind of it's weird um i've spent quite a
bit of time traveling in the last
couple of years and i wasn't aware like
i don't think people in america too a
lot of people like never leave america
are aware of how different cultures can
be but there are cultures that just
operate like that like as long as you
know the rules it's fine it's not like
it's lawless there are rules it's just
the rules are you know from the mafia
and those are the rules so instead of
you know the government right
yeah absolutely and like
okay so people might think this is
unethical but it's not because you don't
get anything done in other countries you
have to pay off the police you have to
if you go to another country where
you're potentially going to get killed
or there's like lots of crime and stuff
you have to pay off the police for
information just you know or to tell you
where to go or to tell you if they're
gonna like watch you and make sure
you're gonna be safe so there are a lot
of things you can do to be safe and of
course i had lots of opportunities that
um i could have gone and done and
watched that i chose not to because it
was too much of a gamble uh one example
is we actually ran into i love i love
doing this it was so cool
i i was looking on google maps for areas
that i thought might be um
major crossing points
in
over the texas border i think it was
across from mcallen texas
and i found this one area where the
trump's wall just stopped i was done i
had a drone so i was also like going
over these areas and looking for areas
that would be breaks in the wall and
trump's wall just stopped and there was
like this texan country club
and i'm like there's no way there's not
human trafficking going on here there's
no way they aren't crossing here because
there's just no border walls so we went
there for like four nights
and just stayed there until because we
had been told by our cartel contact they
they typically go over at around 4am
because that's when switch shifts are
for
uh you know american border security
everyone's pretty sluggish at that time
and the first morning we spent there we
ran into human traffickers
uh they had like all these life jackets
uh oh i i was so embarrassing i'm like
what do i do what do i do we're in the
middle of the woods you know there's
potentially armed human traffickers
they're walking towards us and my dora
the explorer ass just walks out from
behind the car and i'm like hola amigos
how are you doing this morning
oh and they they luckily ran off but we
could have followed them maybe would
have gotten some interesting footage but
typically they take two security like
armed guards that pick them off and pick
them up and drop them off luckily we
just ran into the boat men but we
weren't about to find out who they were
being picked up by right so just let
that one be
that seems that seems wise that seems
like a wise decision it's like do we
chase those people that might end up
with you know guns or no
no good i'm glad you're here now you can
be on my podcast exactly i actually
thought about that there i was like you
know what i've got the michaela peterson
podcast going i can't i can't be doing
this
wow okay so how long did this
documentary take to film
i took a little over two weeks that's it
sounds like such a small time but it was
actually meant to be like a mini report
actually know it took more than that my
on the ground time was a little over two
weeks and then i did a few interviews
with uh ali bradley and um
dan lyman from border hawk so that was
done afterwards so i'd say the editing
and filming process has been about four
months
wow and how did your last documentary
perform
crossfire did fantastic i only published
it on my own site so i think i need to
put it on youtube i was a bit concerned
about my youtube channel being taken
down because it's just kind of repeated
clips of violence shootings blood etc
but yeah it did really well like over
you know over a million views on my own
site so that's uh
that's really cool we worked hard on
that but
but this always happens i'll find an
amazing film crew and they always get
poached or taken tucker carlson took my
film crew for that
if you guys don't know um
scooter downey he did crossfire with me
incredibly talented man he's now doing
all of tucker carlson originals videos
go follow him he's doing some of the
most important work in the world right
now and of course
behind the scenes people uh always get
too little appreciation and tend to take
the
blame for any mistakes made by their
more famous
counterparts or bosses i i've seen so
many people that work behind the scenes
get their lives screwed over but um they
deserve way more appreciation all the
people who are doing filming editing uh
all this stuff for big creators
hmm that's fair that's fair so tucker
poached him
i know what a horrible man no no he
tucker could pay him what he deserves i
don't
don't have the fox news budget so i'm
proud of scooter he's doing good work
cool okay so then you have to go and
find another crew how do you locate a
crew that's willing to do that kind of
thing there are very few people
especially within conservatism
right-wing movements that actually do
creative work
it's our own fault for telling everyone
that going into the arts was a mistake
don't do it you can only get trades
otherwise you're a liberal cuck right uh
and then wow shocking we lost the
culture war because we lost the arts
movie making everything that influences
people's souls hearts and minds great
work guys so there's like four
filmmakers on the right wing um my last
two my first no no they would have been
like yeah the first guys i did
documentaries with they got completely
slandered by the right wing uh all lies
uh i'll be talking about that shortly so
they
left and they decided they hated working
with people in right-wing politics and
now work for some leftist channel
they're like y'all are just too insane
uh second guys scooter got um
he got
poached by tucker and then a partner of
scooters john detroit who works with um
he worked with cernovich on his films
and also with scooter a few times uh he
helped me with this american mirage i
helped me i mean he did all the editing
and filming amazing amazing work by john
detroit on this documentary coming out
so uh and i think he wants retire i
don't think he wants to do video work
anymore so i need to go find some more
uh
artsy film people or i'm not gonna have
another documentary but damn it they're
hard to find thanks a lot
you know what i like dennis prager i
grew up listening to him but all those
prageru videos that are like
you shouldn't follow your dreams don't
go into the arts they ruined it for me
oh yeah now fair enough i think daily
wire is doing some interesting work in
that like with um
trying to i know that they're trying to
start
making movies or something like so
they're they're trying to take it on
i was just at their studio a few weeks
ago with michael knowles and we did this
cool little drinking show and i i liked
that i like that they're taking a
different approach it was like a
drinking game so you had to ask each
other questions and vote whether you
thought the other person was going to
say yes or no and then i want to do that
yeah you should absolutely do it i was
the first uh female
guest he had on the show so clearly he
needs to up
up
from the daily wire typical
absolutely typical
um what was i going to say yeah i like
that because they're
creating content that isn't just kind of
the same conservative format of let me
tell you about policy issues for two
hours
we need we need something a bit
different
yeah a little bit more
you know not to say click baity but i
mean
a little bit more entertaining humans we
need to show that we are human beings i
think that's the biggest optics problem
the right has people are like okay you
guys are actually just people who wear
suits and
you don't
you don't like sex you don't like
drinking you don't like music you don't
like arts you don't like any of this you
just like talking about policy and
staring at a camera and it's like well
no no actually conservatives are complex
human beings with lots of interests just
i think we fear talking about those
interests and complexity a lot since
there's so much judgment in uh all
political spheres actually and you're
kind of supposed to stick to that box
like it's kind of like if a liberal
makes a joke in their shows everyone's
like whoa
that's a bit too spicy you're triggering
a lot of us so they kind of have to
adhere to this inhuman standard as well
and then if conservatives are like we're
going to do a drinking show
i think it's less so now but maybe
before you would have gotten a lot of
criticism of that not being a emblematic
of conservative values but i think
that's dissipating and more people are
beginning to uh
beginning to realize that conservatives
need to show a human side as well
yeah well and a lot of the people too
that four years ago or 2016 2017 even
2018 that identified as liberals are now
like maybe i'm not a liberal anymore
because things have gone even further
left
you know yeah yeah yeah
hard to say where anyone is with the
state of the overton window i don't even
think are you even do you even consider
yourself adherent to any political
ideology yourself
um
i've always kind of like veered
libertarian for forever like i remember
in 2012 and they're like what do you
identify with i'm like yeah probably
libertarian what's the what's the party
that says just like
leave me alone and let me think for
myself and i don't need like rules put
on me by anybody
yeah libertarian right maybe ish kind of
i don't know
i don't trust anybody i don't think
anyone like i don't think anyone is that
competent and i think that people who go
into government also aren't that
competent because if you're competent
why not make a business and make hoards
of money
it's like oh no i want to save the world
i'm like you're going to save the world
by going into government right okay
the problem is all of the people who
want power and want to get into politics
or the worst leaders and all the people
who would be great leaders never in
their lives would get into politics so
yeah exactly
that's a huge problem it's a huge
problem and then they villainize
business owners as if like oh those are
the bad guys it's like what i don't know
if i agree with that evil corporate i
mean there are some evil corporations
they're a lot but
we should take out a phone book if they
still exist just open it to a random
page and point to a name and that person
gets to be president for four years
would it work out worse
it would it would probably be fine like
that it can't possibly be worse than
than now right as long as the guy had
the reaction of ah damn it i really
don't want to do this fine i'll leave my
working class job for
four years and make some tough decisions
and i don't really give a [ __ ] what
people think of me or if they hate me or
not whatever
i think that would work out a lot better
than all these like massively because
anytime you're making a political
calculation for okay am i gonna
what decision do i have to make to win
four years from now what decision do i
have to make to win
two years from now you're always going
to be making these like
instant quick hit decisions none of
which have time preference for like holy
[ __ ] how is this going to affect people
10 years from now how is this going to
actually yeah it's all gonna be just for
the election cycle which is a horrendous
way to run a country so so what you're
saying is we should
just have a dictator because that would
just eliminate that problem and perhaps
maybe yeah okay okay no okay here's my
theory actually
um we look at china and everyone can
jump up and down about how angry they
are about you know the social credit
system how oppressive they are blah blah
blah blah right
just because something is bad doesn't
mean it doesn't work
and i think we have to
and i'm not saying we do it it's bad so
don't do it but
it works right it works it's making them
become a global leader in a lot of ways
they are they're finishing their
100-year plan they are getting the south
china sea they aren't having
george floyd to your rights actually
maybe hong kong you know what never mind
i take that back but there are a lot of
aspects to authoritarianism that could
work you can solve a lot of problems
with genocide but doesn't mean you
should do it right so
i think that holy that is a clip and a
half
yeah that's definitely i'm using that
that was that was stalin's argument
though right it was that you know the
russia and that area was going to be
invaded by the west and they needed to
rapidly evolve and the only way to
rapidly evolve
was for you know hundreds of thousands
and potentially millions of people to
die but then they evolved
so it was like i think that that's kind
of where china's coming from too it's
like it doesn't matter you know it's the
culture that needs to survive it's not
the person in the culture
yeah if you don't value individual human
life the way that a liberal society does
although that's becoming questionable um
then of course you're going to make a
decision for this conglomerate this idea
of the nation rather than
the individual and i think there's a
happy mix in there i think we've
probably got too much individualism in
the west to the point where it's like i
am willing to take this entire country
for my own freedom to do whatever i want
to do right uh yeah and lack of
consideration like everyone else has to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps i
don't care if you're like a 90 year old
lady whose family died and probably
would be the morally right thing to go
and care for you and give up a little
bit of my selfishness um i think that
hyper individualism is a problem but of
course
the opposite hyper
um
what's the word i'm looking for michaela
individual i don't know
yeah collectivism thank you hyper
collectivism hyper
um you know
just being about everyone else that that
causes some severe severe issues as well
dehumanization for sure
how do you feel i mean you're on here so
we might as well get controversial how
do you feel about this whole trans thing
that's going on with men in women's
sports or sorry no trans people in
women's sports i guess trans people and
everybody's spores
that i butchered that but that can be
part of the clip too no it's it's
interesting because on on one hand
you know this this is a problem of the
hyper individualization like i can be
anything i want but then also they're
demanding everyone else
except their hyper individualization so
we've got like this disgusting mix of
both like i want to be this collectivist
nation i want to be able to force other
people to do what i say but then i also
want to have these like hyper crazy
individual rights that everyone else has
to adhere to so if i identify as a he
today you have to call me a he by threat
of you know legal action or if it can't
be legal action then i'll make it social
action you will be socially excluded
from civilization and likely fired from
your job that is insanely
authoritarian under the guise of freedom
because they'll pretend like oh this is
my freedom to identify is who i want
this is i'm being liberated to be who i
want to be but if your own liberation
comes at the cost of everyone else's
freedom to even
think
or have opinions well i don't know if
that's really
i don't really know if i called it a
freedom
yeah that's for sure i saw i don't
remember who posted it on instagram but
it was some skateboarding contest i
don't know i think it was college people
they were skateboarding and
um uh you know dude identifying as a
girl one in the girls league and the
person who came in second was like you
know what
i've been you know quiet long enough
this is ridiculous
right and i don't see how that isn't
going to i used to kind of veer away
from this topic because part of the
reason dad
sprung to
infamy or whatever
uh was over the bill c-16 and his
refusal to
call people like you know just
to be made to call people something you
know not
you know anything really um i was like
i'm just gonna delve away from that
topic because it's kind of controversial
i'm not super interested in it but
recently
uh it's gotten to a point i think more
people are speaking out about it that
it's just it's bothering me more and
more like i'm concerned about it with
like a kid in school
whether or not the school is going to go
woke and then she's going to be
competing against men and it's like
yeah we're at a weird point well just it
it doesn't make sense to me because we
split the
categories in sports based on people's
biology not because they're women who
like dresses and you know we i talk with
a higher pitched toys and have longer
hair that's not why we split the
categories you can be the biggest boy in
the world and play in the women's
category because that's what your
biology is so if people are gonna say
well trans people are real because your
gender and your sex are different things
that's their argument right it doesn't
matter if the sex of the transgender
person is they have a penis and that's
you know the biology they're born with
because their gender is different so why
can't we just say okay fine whatever you
can be whatever gender you want if you
want your gender to be male you have to
still compete in the sport of your sex
though
why i don't understand if you want to
split those two things fine but when we
talk about sports we are obviously
talking about people's sex their biology
not their gender expression so like
you're i feel like they're undermining
their own argument by suggesting no sex
and gender are the same
yeah and then and then everybody at the
school is scared to say anything or
they'll be labeled a bully okay i was
smiling there because i forgot i'm
having this conversation with you didn't
you
change your what did you change i don't
even know if it's gender or sex are you
gender i guess in canada
like years ago okay well what's crazy is
that it does say sex on my id card but
yeah i changed my sex to mail i had to
go get a
doctor's note to do it too i'd have a
doctor diagnosed me as male and then i
went to basically our canadian version
of the dmv and went and presented my
doctor's note they started calling me mr
right away and gave me my new
identification and all of that was done
within a matter of like three hours
what year was that
2016.
did that decision like haunt you after
that
i mean i yeah definitely i feel like
it kind of wasn't a piss out of our
institutions doesn't it well we'll know
that for sure but i mean did you end up
in any trouble because you had like man
on your on your id did that ever come to
bite you i can recall maybe three
strange looks from bartenders that's
about it but no one's gonna say anything
what you want to go to jail make a
comment on my id
i do think that people absolutely did
read that when i would like give it bars
and stuff and think wow you pass well
friend yeah yeah it's your job
it's funny the only time uh i ever did
that i was i was at a theater and there
was this massive line it was halloween
so i was dressed as one wonder woman
because that was my usual outfit on
halloween and uh there was a huge line
for the
women's washroom so i went in the men's
washroom they're like you can't be in
here i was like i'm identifying i'm a
man i'm identifying as man they're like
okay so they just sent in a security
guard with me they're like wow we'll
send in a security guard with you i was
like yes
this works the system works they
absolutely the system if you can learn
how to rig the system i think as many
men as possible should join women's
sports you are missing out why wouldn't
you go and win some medals for yourself
in this rigged system it makes no sense
you don't even have to do anything you
don't have to cut anything off you just
identify it doesn't matter and also what
that's going to do is i actually think
that could help a lot of people because
if you had a mass wave of people join
women's sports tomorrow then that would
force the hand of a lot of lawmakers and
politicians to say
ah this really isn't making sense we're
going to have to do something about this
it would rip the band-aid off i think it
would red pill tons of parents and
people partaking in these sports i think
anyone watching this if you are a man
that you know has the ability to go have
some fun and join some women's leagues
uh go do it absolutely win all those
medals while you can in this brief
period of history and save our nation in
the process of doing that you know yeah
you know a few women might lose
scholarships but that's better than
uh our whole nation being in delusion
for the rest of eternity
hmm
you know what i'm not you know normally
what i've been saying is just fight back
like women on teams should be saying no
but they're not so i mean it would
certainly be a lot faster if suddenly
there were no women on any team because
men are going to be objectively stronger
period i was like suddenly there are no
women and then maybe someone will be
like um
uh maybe maybe we've gone backwards
well they rely on the argument of it's
just a few here and there what are you
talking about you know
biological men aren't dominating all of
these fields it's like okay it's just a
few it's not an argument
because it could be more than just a few
one day you know it will be it will be
yeah it's not an argument to say well
you only have two or three examples
we don't want any more than that we
don't want more examples we want this to
stop
yeah insane
so
let me see i have a whole list of
questions here that i wanted to ask you
about that i haven't got to well we
talked about american mirage so that's
the documentary and i will link it below
or in show notes if people want to check
it out
um
let me see
let me see
okay well this is this could be fun
um can you tell me about the south
african farm attacks
oh yeah i mean it's been it's been a bit
since i did that documentary but still
my most popular to date farmlands uh the
the attacks on
basically white farmers because there's
so much racial animosity in the country
against white people who a lot of
south african
individuals now blame for
any sort of crises the country faced
whether it be poverty issues wealth
disparities certainly all of this is
blamed on the evil white man and of
course the
the country does have a history of
apartheid but um
i don't want to get into that there's a
lot of there's a lot of complexity there
but unfortunately the politicians are
not working in large part to try to heal
this racial animosity but instead
they're in flaring it you have political
parties that actually have
elected positions that have you know
members of parliament that are calling
for the murder of white people in the
country kill shoot the boar the leader
of the eff has chanted to his audience
um
absolutely nuts so it's not a lot of
people would be like oh this is a
conspiracy talking about the murder of
whites in south africa as a conspiracy
no it's probably one of the very few
situations where a country has said hey
there is a racial group being oppressed
here and you can actually point to
politicians in said country calling for
the murder of this group that like it's
not there's nothing conspiratorial about
it people just don't like the fact that
there's a country where white people are
being oppressed for their race which is
crazy because no one wants to be
oppressed no one wants there to be a
country where white people are being
oppressed but we do need to talk about
it
so have things gotten better or worse
since that documentary
i mean i i haven't been back there in a
lot of my judgments about
yeah these very complex situations come
from being on the ground but i did do an
interview i think within this year with
ian cameron where we spoke about the
riots and the
social downfall in south africa mass
lootings it does seem it's absolutely
gotten worse things are not improving
clearly blaming another race for all of
your country's problems rather than
working to heal that divide and fix the
nation and get rid of corruption does
not solve political issues and we're
seeing the effects of that people are
essentially living
like a mad max life if you're in south
africa and this is something i mentioned
in my documentary like if you are a
south african especially if you are a
white person living in south africa it
actually doesn't matter what race you
are you need to be armed you need need
to be prepared to take care of yourself
and defend yourself because the
government aren't going to do it lord
knows they might be the ones to harm you
too you can't trust the government in
that country you can't they are
unbelievably corrupt
yikes
okay
okay going in a different direction
i follow you on across social media so i
hear about this sometimes what's the
most ridiculous rumor you've heard about
yourself
oh the most ridiculous rumor i mean
there's some good ones i like um
obviously the the rumor that i'm like
secretly an anti-fun hope not hate spy i
find very funny that that's kind of the
major one that'll not
hope not hate is an ngo organization in
uh britain that kind of do a lot of
investigations and expose on right
wingers and lobbying against uh people
in fact they both lobbied to have my
patreon account
um taken down and succeeded in that and
they lobbied to have me banned from the
uk um i met with them once
2017 to speak to them about them
lobbying against my patreon account i
tried to record the meeting but it was
just the worst audio ever and it
actually ended up coming up in a court
case i i brought against patreon but um
met with them once to confront them
about whether they lobbied patreon or
not and uh the fact of me having met
with them once
someone recorded me saying it on a phone
call and it got spread through all of
these right wing circles and everyone
was like she spoke to them we don't have
any context but clearly this means she's
working for them and she's secretly a
spy and that just kind of became the
narrative amongst a lot of um
yeah far-right far-right accounts that i
that i work for the organization that
took my income away and got me banned
from a country this is a huge problem in
any sort of kind of more fringe
political circles as they're obsessed
with drama though and they love rumors
and everyone likes to feel like they've
got they've got the extra in i know
you're a fraud i know you're a fed i
know you're this and people will purity
spiral into oblivion until like any
radical movement they end up going full
stall and here and executing everyone
around them and all of their supporters
because they think that everyone is
secretly working against them so i have
no interest in being a part of any
far-right circles there's so much mental
illness there and these people are more
catty and about like
gossiping than any actual political
movement but you guys enjoy that why
don't you
although i don't think you have a
far-right audience so
i don't think so i think most people i
don't really know i think most people
probably have a similar stance
to me i don't know if that makes it an
echo chamber or not but i think it's
like libertarian which is just like
i don't know i don't i don't see i mean
probably more of a conservative bent but
then whenever i say anything that's not
like pure conservative they're like ah
shrooms
okay when i say far right too i want to
specify i don't mean far right the way
the media use it where it's like haha
you have questions about immigration and
you want to preserve your culture you're
you're a far-right nazi you know i'm
talking about like actual like weird
fringe people
okay that's good to specify yeah what's
the difference what are the actual what
are the actual far right people what are
the actual far right i mean like if you
want to kill a bunch of minorities to
try and because you think that's gonna
i don't know save the white race or
something i think that's pretty damn
insane if you're i think talking about a
whole lot of
yeah conspiracy about conspiracies about
how everyone that is like slightly more
liberal than you that's just normal
conservative is actually like a
left-wing psyop um certainly you can get
down a lot of like massive conspiracy
uh trails about
i don't know
it's it's so hard to even distinguish
anymore because unfortunately a lot of
a lot of conspiracies don't really seem
like conspiracies anymore because that's
large government institutions just keep
enacting the most conspiratorial [ __ ]
ever like mass surveillance you know
we're gonna do microchips and stuff it's
like man i can't even define who the
crazy people are anymore because of you
guys you're just like taking you're
going on like schizo blogs and taking
your ideas straight from them um but no
i do think i still do think that there
are
oh you know how i define people that are
like far like crazy radicals on either
side when their politics aren't
motivated by love of something like i i
love my country i love my family that's
what motivates me is like love for these
things wanting to preserve them but when
their politics is centered around hatred
for the other group like my whole
politics is i hate right wingers i hate
white people that's what my politics are
you're probably a crazy person if your
old politics are i hate immigrants i
hate brown people you know
i hate liberals that's my politics and
that's what i center my shows about
because you'll watch some shows and it's
like wow you haven't actually talked
about anything you want to preserve
anything you want to build anything
beautiful or good you've just talked
about how much you hate people yeah i
don't know that's what i would consider
fringe and crazy i don't like those
people i don't i think they're just part
of the whole
modern
you know deconstructionism you don't
actually have anything to offer all you
have is things to destroy
okay i like that that's a good
definition so why did you get banned off
of patreon
uh they said i was partaking in
activities which might lead to
um
human loss of life which my lawyers took
one look at that and they were like this
is a ridiculous argument like
99 of your daily activities could
potentially lead to loss of human life
you have someone who does crazy stunts
right that could potentially lead to a
loss of their life you have someone that
goes and partakes in a blm riot or or
protest which a lot of people who use
patreon did well that did lead to loss
of life and none of them got banned
right so i partook in a protest against
a human trafficking ship
um
and
it didn't actually do anything the ship
just went on its merry way of course the
left would view it as a rescue ship i
viewed it as human trafficking um
it went on its very way nothing happened
so if you're going to ban me from your
site because i partook in something that
didn't but could have led to the loss of
life i mean they're probably gonna have
to ban thousands of other creators that
promoted or partook in the blm protests
which did lead to loss of life but of
course there's no consistency there
because it was political lobbying by
hope not hate that got me removed not
any sort of
real platform on the website or anything
that i had agreed to when i joined the
site
fair um do you have so for this
migration issue that you've been
focusing on more recently after doing
your documentary do you have suggestions
for how to improve
the entire situation from both sides
america and people trying to get saved
it's funny funny you ask because i
didn't this is a documentary that i i
didn't have any defined conclusions at
the end i kind of leave it up to the
viewer
to to make up their mind
um
you i think you have to have a
consistency you people actually have to
know what your policies are because when
they don't they're willing to go on
this
i i compare the whole thing i filmed i
compared to hell i use like levels of
dante's inferno and different um
references to types of hell within
different cultures for all the names of
my chapters
because it was the only comparison i
could make
of what i witnessed there like you've
got tapachula stadium which is right
across from guatemala and it's like a
limbo people are there for months and
months and months and months on end just
sleeping under the hot sun sleeping
under trees they have no idea whether
they're going to be allowed to stay in
mexico they have no idea whether they're
going to be deported they have no idea
what's happening at all it's just this
like hellish limbo and then
they they continue on the track and they
basically have to find traffickers you
can take a
you can take a train up to
the u.s border called the beast it's
actually got three names the the trade
the death train train delay buret or the
train of unknowns they they have these
three it's horrifying
and people die all the time on there it
tends to be run by the zetas they'll
make you pay fees they'll rape you on
the train because you can't get off
there's no where you can go people will
go on the top of the train and get
knocked off by tree branches lose limbs
beneath the tracks and everything and
they take this death train you know flip
a coin just to get up to the border and
then find human traffickers and pay to
get across maybe get shot maybe get you
know kidnapped
uh the state i was in kamalipas
interesting story
um a lot of migrants tend to get
kidnapped by the cartel in mexico
because they're nameless faceless people
right if you want to get rid of a crime
or if you want to commit a crime
especially something like rape or murder
then
rape or murder someone who can't be
tracked or found
and that's that's going to be migrants
in i think it was 2011 right near where
we were staying they had the san
fernando massacres done by the cartel in
tomalipes there where they kidnapped 200
people off of passenger buses and took
them to
there's other like a field or a stadium
and gave them hammers knives and various
different weapons and made them all
fight to the death
why with the yeah
literally squid game in real life no
joke oh my gosh
and
they the winner got to become a sicario
for their game so they had these 200
people like fight the death brutally in
what they could what was described by
police as gladiator style
matches and all of the buses just showed
up in reynosa where i was staying empty
with like no one on them and just
luggage right and then they buried all
these people in mass graves that they
found later but this is this is like the
the risks and the lives of these
migrants who go through mexico
it's just like a reality that they take
that's horrifying i've been re-watching
game of thrones
i know just this is so loosely
associated
starting now but but anyway it's violent
right and i'm like this isn't real like
this can't it's shocking to think uh a
culture can
degenerate to that point where where you
can pit 200 people against each other
and then the winner joins the gang
that's like so absurd for the average
person to even believe is possible or
like oh that would never happen here or
and
yeah it's i'm so torn about this
immigration issue because the people
trying to get in are people
that are suffering so badly right to to
risk all those things to try and bring
like them and their kids to some place
that isn't as scary like no wonder
people are trying to get in
this is what pisses me off sometimes and
i don't blame you for thinking it at all
because this is what people are told but
they're like oh they're trying to get
out of this situation that is so scary
like 90 of these people are economic
migrants they could tell me i'm naive
is that what you're saying lauren
how could you know like no one's telling
anyone this it's not it's not your fault
um but like the sushiyate where i went
across
um to there's a little town i think it's
called chiapas
beautiful beautiful area any one of
these migrants coming from south america
could have stayed there in fact we
interviewed the mayor of this little
town across from the succiate and she
said they have hundreds thousands of
migrants come and stay in that little
town and they thrive there she's a
really good mayor too holy [ __ ] she just
um when i was there they were having a
parade because they had built uh
light posts all across the street to
stop crime because putting light in city
areas tends to reduce reduce crime
drastically so this was like her project
they're putting light posts all across
the town gorgeous town of course you're
not going to have the same
you know big living that you could find
in america but you'd be safe you'd be
safe if you stayed there so when i see
people oh i'm gonna drag my kid across
the darian gap i'm gonna drag my kid on
the the beast you know let them fall
between the wheels that i have a better
chance of getting a passport to america
no for the most part it isn't for safety
no i don't believe that some people for
sure but most are economic migrants and
admit as much
you know what part of me is like i don't
oh part of me i don't want to blame them
because they get told it's easier than
it actually is human traffickers tell
them that it's not going to be as
dangerous as they think it is so maybe
they do genuinely actually no i do think
a lot of them genuinely believe it's not
going to be this insane crazy
death trap of a trip so maybe it isn't
so much their fault but if they were
given the truth i think a lot more
people would stay in the southern safer
states of
mexico like chiapas and and make a life
there instead of
yeah taking this hell trip north
everything you learn is a lie everything
everything i know is a lie i don't like
i don't trust i have no idea what's
going on anywhere
anymore um okay okay another question do
you get sick i mean you obviously you
still have an online presence and you're
back at it after having a kiddo so do
you get sick of the negative attention
you receive does that bother you at all
or are you pretty resilient
it's interesting it doesn't bother me
but
the idea of it bothering my family
bothers me
that's it yeah i'm like way past i'm way
past that and i there
janice joplin quote freedom is just
another word for nothing left to lose
what what are people gonna call me oh
you're gonna call me a [ __ ]
i'm a woman on the internet like come up
with something more creative that's like
the go-to okay i'm a [ __ ] all right i'm
a left-wing spy okay i'm a far-right
extremist ooh i'm a mass murderer
these are good ones right i don't care
anymore i don't you can call me any name
in the book and i've been called it a
million times before but i do care about
how i think it might affect um
you know people who aren't as crazy as
me within my life right especially
i'm kind of hoping i'm counting on the
internet being obliterated by some crazy
person before my son gets old enough to
to read internet
comments
nah he'll probably think you're cool
yeah i mean or he'll be embarrassed for
a while and then later he'll think
you're cool something like that
yeah absolutely well i plan on uh yeah
setting up a pretty cool life for him so
okay are you gonna do public school like
are you gonna do the schooling system
not a chance no way no way no way i like
i like my child i like my son i don't
want him hating himself for being a male
i don't want him being told that oh you
should ask questions about that at the
ripe age of six years old right no i'm
i've joked with my husband before that
we'd rather send him to an islamic
school than a public school because at
least they have some conception of
reality like
gender that's crazy that's crazy but
that's true
yeah yeah
yeah but um yeah probably a catholic
school i think that um the more i think
about it the more i think kids thrive in
schools that don't have both genders
i i don't know like i really didn't go
to a school like that yeah yeah
especially young boys oh my god maybe
boys
okay maybe boys i can actually get
behind that but can you imagine
going to an all-girls school
oh yeah that does that does sound
hellish yeah also for boys maybe but i
mean don't make all go make girls go to
all girls schools sounds awful teenage
girls are like they're like the worst
people on the planet yeah i was thinking
about this you let me know what you
think um
whether high school is matriarchal
because they will punish
any sort of physical confrontation to
the extreme so even if you like defend
yourself and like punch back at a bully
attacking you like you're gonna get
suspended you're gonna get in massive
trouble any sort of physical
confrontation but kids can absolutely
ruthlessly bully the [ __ ] out of each
other until like
socially social exclusion that's a very
uh
female high school
girl tactic right social exclusion
rumors all of this sort of
gossipy nonsense and life ruining
through social crippling that thrives in
high schools but any sort of physical
confrontation no no no no no um so it's
very like matriarchal and it really
messes with people's heads i think
yeah i completely agree do you remember
honesty box on facebook no i don't oh
yes i do
yeah yes i i haven't heard that in a
while huh honestly wow you're giving me
flashbacks yeah
can you explain because i i reckon a lot
of people watching
won't even know what that is okay okay
so honesty box i think that was around
in 2008
and it was in facebook i remember it was
just after i got facebook which was only
a few years after facebook existed and
it was this box where if you were
friends with someone you could type in
anything you wanted you just tell them
something and so for teenagers it was
something awful it's like oh i know you
did this
and you know we're going to come to your
house and it's completely anonymous and
and so it uh
it was like it was a night they took it
off i don't know what happened to it i
think it just didn't go well it's like
say nice things to your friends ha and
her teenage girls right yeah no it would
always be yeah like
i it would either be like something
that's like i have a crush on you but i
never want to tell you or something like
that or just something absolutely
horrendous what a terrible idea
i cannot believe you've reminded me of
this thing
did you ever um get your house egged in
high school
no
no shocking lots of people i have no
idea why i mean people didn't know who
my dad was thank goodness
that like that happened now and not back
then because people egged all the time
is that normal or is that a canadian
thing
i don't know maybe you'd have to ask
americans i'm canadian so i got my saved
once i think it was because i rejected
going to uh our version of prom with a
guy but um
we didn't get our house oh yeah yeah i
have a vague memory i can't remember why
i don't know but yes there was there was
yes i do remember that and then yeah
that was you know each other's houses as
well oh and then
um
i feel so bad i remember i was walking
to a little halloween party i rarely got
invited to parties in high school but i
was on the volleyball team so i just
always had that little like shoe in the
door i'm like
hey i might be a loser but i'm on the
volleyball team and i'm pretty good at
that
um i remember walking with a friend of
mine to this party and there were a
bunch of guys from the school they had
taken cartons of eggs and they were
driving around just throwing them at
people and my friend got hit in the
stomach covered an egg um but yeah
people used to do that all the time
tp'ing each other's houses oh my
goodness we were horrendous to each
other i remember the autistic girl in my
gym class getting horrendously bullied
horrifically bullied by other girls
geez
wow
i wonder if that's like you went to
public did you go to public school or
private school uh public i went to
private school when i was younger but
that's a very expensive
thing to go to my i didn't grow up in
like a super wealthy family so we went
to public school later uh when i was
like
like i was like 12 or 13 when we
switched to public school 13. i wonder
if like because i know people all my
friends were in public schools i went to
public school for my entire life and
that was like the norm that kind of
behavior but i've i know people who've
gone to private schools and that
behavior isn't norm i was like oh did
you guys do like was there a group of
people that did ketamine behind the
subway next to your school too they're
just like
what
the smoke pit of course
yeah the smoke pit this like literally
does every school have that
every public school hang up on a smoke
pit yeah you'd have like the three
characters that would always show up to
class high
yeah consistently uh we had one kid i
still can't explain it to this day one
kid got kidnapped and also got stabbed
within a period of two years completely
unrelated events
okay i had like things like that
happened to my high school too
like
literal things like that yeah stabbings
and things i was like this is just high
school
yeah i mean like maybe that's not that
shouldn't be experienced did you ever do
a rival school as well
that would like do like you know in in
private jarvis like oh
yeah you've got a yeah ours was
brookswood you've got a rival school and
uh you you just play sports against them
and you know you make nice signs and
stuff if you're in a private school
that's that's your rivalry but then in
public school it's like the brookswood
kids came in and smashed all the
computers in our library and left spray
paint and like a dead pig on the table
[Laughter]
ah
good times okay yeah yeah nah i'm doing
private school for scarlet i'm doing the
bougie school none of this like
crack behind the school for her
it's gonna be expensive drugs they're
only doing cocaine at private
i'm just kidding
not laced
nothing in there just yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's amazing how much just yeah what
school you go to where you go to school
will affect you for the rest of your
life like those those experiences holy
like i'm not gonna i wasn't i wasn't at
like some inner city school of course
there was still like i i'm remembering
like the worst of the shenanigans that
happened right now of course but
if you're at like an inner city school
in america where they've literally got
like the metal detector machines when
you walk into school your life is
effed you're done for there's nothing
like i'm sorry it's very maybe you can
be like the one percent of ben carson's
that somehow work their way out of that
situation
but if you are yeah if you start off
with that at foot like you're done for
so i understand to an extent yeah why
people will go to such extremes to like
change where they live and wanting to
have a better starting point for their
kids but um
yeah geez
that's crazy and then the way things are
going too like they're like oh like
getting okay so i'm relocating to miami
getting scarlett into a
kindergarten class is like the bane of
my existence i literally had an
interview um although the school looks
amazing so i was like okay i'll do the
interview um but
it's it's tricky it's a tricky situation
um especially i guess i guess there's
been an influx to private school since
covid because private schools stayed
open for little kids and public schools
closed so anyone who could barely afford
it was like okay it's cheaper than a
nanny
and so
it's a wild situation
it's a wild situation when are you
moving to miami
uh hopefully this summer i was really
allergic to nashville i was in nashville
and i'm oh okay that's like the daily
wire people are all there
yeah and nashville's really cool i
really like nashville and then i was
i've been like chronically ill since i
got there with bronchitis and asthma and
was like whoa i haven't been this sick
since i was like on immune suppressants
when i was young and then i was like oh
it's tree allergies and they have like
10 months
of tree allergies in nashville it's one
of the worst places in north america and
i'm like the token bubble person so i
went there and i'm just like can't
breathe so
i am i'm gonna be in miami late next
month doing the fresh and fit podcast i
think they need to get back to me so i
was going to say if you were in the area
you should have been coming with me or
uh we'll hang out with you oh that would
be so fun i would do that okay hit me up
i should be in miami by then so that way
will you okay i'll um i'll ask if you
can come on with me that'd be that'd be
great i'm sure they'll hate us in the
best kind of ways
nah i was on their show oh have you done
their show are they nice i don't all i
know is that they kind of they'll be
nice to you no they've got a really
they've got a really intense like
online thing that they do
but in person i mean they were
ridiculously polite
okay yeah i don't i don't know anything
about them other than i've seen like
peripheral drama about them on i think i
saw like ethan klein did a podcast with
him
yeah claiming that um
i don't even know what it was it was
like this girl just saying that she had
drinks with them and then they didn't
buy her an uber and told her to get
mouthwash and i don't know if it was
supposed to sound like an assault story
or if it was just like
trying to make them look bad but it
ended up being a little ridiculous uh i
was probably trying to make them look
bad i don't trust anything ethan kline
says or does that thinks for that matter
yeah yeah he's got such a hate boner for
you i don't understand he does
he's really rude it is
and it'll be like totally uncalled for
it'll be like you or your dad will say
something like hey ethan like that
wasn't a great that wasn't a very nice
statement like i thought we had a good
show together and then he'll retweet it
like
i hope your evil daughter that's a [ __ ]
that you know tries to force people to
eat meat and got you hooked on drugs
dies i'm like oh
did you have like some personal falling
out with this guy like what happened
that's so funny no i said that maybe if
he lowered the carbs in his diet he'd be
a happier person he didn't take
he didn't take kindly to that you don't
want to tell a man like ethan he needs
to lower his carbs that's a nuclear bomb
to someone like that very dangerous
statement honestly it's your fault you
brought all this hellfire down upon you
basically
okay lauren i would continue this but i
have to run um
if okay first off if people don't follow
you and if they're interested in your
documentary where should they go yes you
can follow my twitter at lauren
underscore southern or just look at my
name on youtube i don't know how
suppressed it is these days but i'm sure
if you google it enough maybe on the
20th page you'll find it um
yeah thanks for having me on this is
always a blast and congrats on all the
success of your show and your move to
miami hopefully i'll see you there
yeah yeah yeah keep me posted about when
you show up and we'll figure out how to
do something that would be fun it's good
all right
bye i don't know what you do for a sign
off cool i don't know why no that was
perfect okay i'm keeping that though
[Music]